[Music]
i give salam to my people in bangladesh
salaam to the people of marrakesh
brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to another episode
from the house uh the house show ensure
as you guys know
um on this episode on this specific set
it's more calm
relaxed mellow and we've got an amazing
guest may allah bless him someone i've
really wanted to meet been watching his
videos if i'm even mistaken maybe even
before i came to islam i think i was
watching some of your videos
bless you brother uh dean um well yes
that's why you need to train mashallah
how many stripes have you got
three three stripes mashallah bjj you
know i'm considering getting into bjj
i'll do a bit of boxing but
you know um i'm trying to get hijab down
um so
you know but you can't just say three
stripes oh freeze oh free strap
black belt free straps yes inshallah
yeah sorry thanks for creating my
muhammadi job
inshallah yeah i'm interested in bjj you
know need to know how to work on the
ground as well
it's it's and i see some of the stuff
that you do and i'm going to tag some of
your videos also about
healthy eating it's quite interesting i
think it's really important making those
little life changes because a lot of
people are suffering from cancer
and especially
he's going through his login she find
everyone it's a very deadly disease
uh but um brother dean um so
we're doing a reaction video so this is
more for the youngsters you know for our
youth inshallah
so i found this video on instagram i
found it very very interesting
and always you talk a lot about you know
christianity uh
you know with your guests and uh the
oneness of allah um
so i wanted to watch it together and i
want your reaction to in charlie
um so here we go so this this this guy
on the right um he's he's speaking to
her
some say that this guy is a youtuber
instagrammer but that this girl was
speaking to someone else
but he was pretending to speak to her
but besides the point
if you see it we'll watch it you'll see
what i mean let's just say where's jesus
where's jesus yes as jesus grew up
he learned more and more about god
jesus is god how can you learn more and
more about himself
that's a good question you see because
it said
jesus grew up he learned more and more
about god his father
because he used to walk the earth like
us friend and read the bible
so he would learn more about himself
yes if i read the bible
myself sometimes oh friend by reading
the bible
well i can do that by reading the bible
how friends
it can say what other people do and then
i and then
they i do that too true that's so true
so okay well look call me back and you
read it and call me back
it should say where's she okay so
i found that so interesting you know
like i was just randomly watching it
um and she's reading it she's a little
child i don't know how she is how old
she is you know one thing about me i
can't tell how old the child is
like i was i don't know she's probably i
don't know three years old sometimes
but it's so interesting as as a child
you know the fitra like we believe the
innate disposition
how it just kicks in you can see her
face at the beginning she's reading and
she's absorbing it she goes
like the face you know when you have
this like you know when someone just
clicks when someone says something to
you and you're like
yeah it's quite profound i just found it
really amazing how
you know as a young child that fitra
just kicked in you know um and what's
your take on it like since you
um exactly what you said i mean it
reminds me there's this uh
study that i often quote i think it was
it was done at the oxford university yes
yeah yeah you know about the studies
yeah 52 researchers and you know
they concluded at the end and this is
not this is from a secular institution
yes it's not based off of exactly any
kind of uh religious
so they concluded through all these
studies that the belief in god is
natural and pretty much you know
one of the researchers from there he
talks about how if a child
you know was left alone it would grow up
to believe in a creator exactly
a lot of these things that's part of
nature but now he's what he's doing he's
nurturing he's trying to nurture
to go ahead and make her believe that
jesus is about god but what has me
thinking here is what god's learned
about himself
i mean that limited it reminds me of i
think it's what is it mark 13 32 when
jesus peace be upon him when he was
asked when is that day
yeah when is the hour here right yeah
yeah yeah he was like yeah
i don't know it's like why are you
asking me pretty much yeah yeah
no man no no not no angels angels are
but god yeah yeah so this is something
because
when the people know i mean uh for
instance okay we talked about
um if i'm looking for a bodyguard yeah
right if i'm looking for a bodyguard
i want someone who fits a certain
description right
he's going to be black belt like you
said like yourself
well
uh engagement yeah and all these other
things what's the responsibility so
there's qualities that you need to look
for for someone who's gonna be your
bodyguard yes yeah you're not gonna get
someone who's in crutches
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah limping on one
layer exactly exactly exactly so when
we're looking for
the qualities of the creator he's got
qualities
exactly yeah when i say he i mean he's
not male or female we just
language yes so now there are certain
qualities one that he's all-knowing
exactly the creator's all-knowing right
he doesn't live or die yes right he
doesn't eat sleep rest go to the
bathroom exactly
jesus peace be upon him who we love and
adore is one of the mightiest messengers
ever sent
to mankind who came with the same
message you always hear me repeat it
worship the creator not the creation
just like all the other messengers and
muhammad just being the last
piece of muslim upon them all he now he
ate
he slept he didn't know and this this is
one of the most powerful
things that he just he didn't he didn't
know that doesn't like put him down or
anything
right yes this is something that's
that's showing that now god is
all-knowing
jesus wasn't he can't be god period
exactly yeah nice
it's amazing you know it's just when we
sometimes give dollar to people and
you see that fitrah uh it kicks in you
know
it's it just it just it just happens you
speak to them and
they can't even deny it and it's like
they just want to disbelief
you know it's just like you're looking
at me thinking you know yourself within
yourself
that he can't because mohammed we went
to ghana and this is where i've got this
shirt from uh with this nice african
thing going on here
and we were speaking to them and in a
nutshell family was having a discussion
which i'll link
the video with two rappers in ghana and
they were saying
like no god can't eat or drink you know
but then they would come back
to kind of defend the trinity they were
sincere actually they were quite
sincere but they were learning but you
can see they were like no god can't eat
or drink but we're like this is what you
believe and they're like oh
not really we don't so you can see the
fitter kicking and the finger is
it's just you know it ignites and this
is what you know makes islam so
beautiful
because if there's any christians
watching this you know one of the one of
the things that's so unique about islam
besides other religions is that you know
we don't just single out allah in what
he does his actions he's all sustainer
or provider
and this is a lot of people believe in
this the quraish believes in this
they're taking out they said yeah we
accept you know allah created us
you know but where did they mess up
where did they go wrong they went wrong
with allah's
singling out in worship yeah so that's
what's different
in islam that we have that's really
unique that when we worship
god we worship him alone and this is
where a lot of
other religious belief systems have gone
wrong where they've said
okay and even some people in islam where
they would go through the prophet
muhammad like directly they will ask
to him and be it other people be it
through jesus
be it through um a lot of buddhist
believe that but
a lot of people they go through down
down this route why because in a car
they were
really righteous and you you know where
sinners this this notion is from shaytan
you know
allah says turn to me alone
no partners allah does not need no
partners and another part of the tahrir
is
his asmr safari his names and attributes
which comes to his all-knowing the
all-powerful
so we come and say look this this girl
here this young little girl
she acknowledged she acknowledged
allah's
god almighty hold on a second he's good
but how does no automatically clicks you
know he clicks in
and also for example he's the most
powerful you know but he got crucified
by his own creation you know it all and
it just makes sense and this is what
makes islam so unique and brothers and
sisters if you're watching this our
christian friends
this is what makes islam islam and it's
very unique
and inshallah if you can look more into
it read the quran
it was just a little reaction video but
it is anything else you want to say
this is i mean i i know we're short on
time but this is one of those when you
talk about the pure monotheism
yes this is something that fits with the
human nature this is why people get
drawn
from islam forget about everything else
i mean you don't see i mean
you know that people attack this that
and the other it takes some some more
context to it yeah
but there this is something the the pure
monotheism you don't see the theology of
islam many people attacking it
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the creator exactly this is something
that connects with human nature exactly
something that we call people too
before you get into all the other things
yeah why can't i have a girlfriend
you know what islam says about you know
all these other issues side notes
many fake issues right yeah the
jurisprudence of islam
this is what we call people to call out
yes to the creator of the loan people
are seeking purpose they want to know
purpose
if they're smart you know if you ended
up on the moon you want to know why
you're there exactly i open say maybe
you have a starbucks chill but at the
end of the day why
why are you there on the moon exactly
why are you there why are you on this
earth
for what you listen that's it have some
you know go to some parties kick it
that's it exactly but the homework that
i usually leave people to do is
call out to the creator yes to the
ultimate reality the most merciful
and ask for guidance it's simple it's
straightforward exactly
yes exactly you don't need to go through
you know
allah doesn't have like some uh
secretary or let me go through him allah
doesn't need that yeah you know
just go directly to allah inshallah um
yeah that's about your brother and
sisters
inshallah i hope you guys have benefited
um inshallah if there's any specific
reactions that you have that we haven't
seen
comment on the section below give us the
links we can check them out and do
reaction with our guests inshallah
uh bless you for coming inshallah it was
a pleasure uh inshallah